消费者其实是跟沃尔玛跟山姆跟河马建立了一个长期的信任合同。
基本上不太需要犹豫空间的去挑选。
在这里面买我所需要的品类具体的商品对吧？
但是作为渠道来说作为这个零售商来说。
他是在不停的更换他的供应商的。
他也能给消费者带新鲜感吗？
所以消费者跟代工商的品牌无法建立长期的关系。
所以代工商的品牌想要借说。
我经过山姆来树立自己的品牌形象。
跳过零售商去跟消费者建立长期的关系。
他需要更多的营销的功夫。
这就是博弈啊？
我怎么样用好我进入了山姆的这六个月。
我怎么样用好我在河马录书商品。
都不是品牌录书商品的这么六个月或者一年的时间。
哇 这个很精彩呀？
但是好就好在呢？
也不是只有一个山姆。
我们还有河马还有永辉。
甚至还有淘宝有京东。
京东不是现在有七仙吗？
还有很多的选择
同样我作为一个零售的工厂也好品牌也好。
我今天在你这里下架了。
我明天就可以在河马上架。
因为我也是同步在做大量的努力。
在向所有的商超输出我的产品。
输出我的能力
大家其实这个博弈双方。
你说渠道有一点强势吧？
但我也觉得品牌方也自有自己的生存之道。
这个我们可能到后面可以再聊一个品牌方。
他要放弃什么执念。
好 那我们现在开始。
大家好 欢迎来和我们一起逛街。
今天这期节目的灵感呢？
还是来自我的大档Zoe。
他在小红书里爱上了卧极仙。
但是他家不在沃尔玛小程序的配送范围内。
所以他就自己人肉去里趟沃尔玛。
有了大量的感触
同时我们也看到山姆被约谈之后。
沃尔玛中国多个重要的高管职位发生了人员变动。
所以我们决定从观察者和消费者的角度。
都来聊一聊山姆和沃尔玛。
山姆可能是最近10年在线上线下最热门的商超品牌。
也是第一个将仓储式超市高端会员卡。
做到了中国老百姓日常生活中的品牌。
沃尔玛则是一个存在我们的记忆当中。
超过20年的大超市品牌。
在过去两年呢？
他以自由品牌卧极仙又重新建立了形象。
关于卧极仙必买报品的内容。
在社交媒体上已经和山姆和马不相上下。
所以我们今天就有了这一期内容。
上海其实只有三家卧尔玛。
但是呢？
卧极仙他的配送范围又非常的小。
他只有一公里和三公里两个范围。
生鲜内类其实就一公里配送。
一些常温的冷冻的品可以配送到三公里。
像你在五公里十公里范围内。
你就没有办法使用他的小程序。
你需要购买到一个很大的额度。
在付运费才能买
就有点像电商一样了。
所以我才去了一个。
离家有十公里左右的一个。
大的卧尔玛去逛街。
我回想一下我上一次真的走进一家。
卧尔玛可能得有四五年了吧？
我可能时间更久
我在工作中看到了大量和卧极仙。
卧尔玛相关的报道。
身边的记者朋友他们去参加完。
卧尔玛卧极仙的活动。
回来也会跟我分享很多。
我这次看到了他们的新品很棒。
小红书上也反复的刷到。
我都没吃过
当时我就觉得这不行。
这么多好的产品我也没吃过。
也没有买过
也没有去逛过他们那些升级后的。
那些升仙店社区店。
卧尔玛在现在全中国。
大概四五百家
我不知道他大概的分部份。
但北京上海应该是不太多了。
上海就三家
我去了那一家之后。
和你四五年前
或者和我十年前
在老家逛过的卧尔玛是完全一样的。
其实后来我发现在卧尔玛的定义里。
我逛的那一家是改造后的卧尔玛。
并不是没有改造
所以给我的感觉很老旧。
而是他已经改造了。
所以他改造的不是这种装修。
灯光
他改造的是里面的选品。
有一个他们一直在宣传点。
就是他把他的价格做得很大。
他比如说这个东西是卖19块9。
你就会很远很远的。
看到一个巨大的19.9元的指示牌。
分区也做得非常的明显。
这是他的改造
同样的就还有改他的成列。
他的选品
比如说我当时在那个卧尔玛的3楼。
他那层应该几乎80%都是卧极限。
感觉像是一个改造完成过程中的卧极限。
比如说当时我看到他有很多的大的指示牌。
告诉你要欢迎试吃。
但是你看底下的成列。
没有任何试吃的东西。
也没有工作人员
我以为那个展台会像山姆一样。
是一个专门的试吃的点。
他有好几个这样的点。
但是他都没有配人。
也没有配小车
小车什么都没有
整个的动线设计是这样的。
你所有熟悉的大品牌。
比如说像统一
康师傅摆饰乐视薯片。
都在沿线两岸
还有农夫山泉
左右两边侧面的柜台。
全部是我们熟悉的这种大品牌。
而中间全部是卧极限。
应该叫摊尺蛇的路线。
然后这样一路一路逛过去。
卧极限的品
比我在网上看到的宣传。
是要多出百倍的
真的非常丰富
有一种你选不过来。
比如说同样巧克力糖果的柜台里。
你能想象到和想象不到的。
组合出来的糖果的味道。
我就会反复去看他们的代工厂。
是谁跟哪个品牌合作的。
卧极限是百分百隐藏掉了。
品牌方的
是完全看不到的
但是你通过那个产品信息。
你可以看到比如有金麦郎。
有很多国厂的
我们没有听过的一些厂家。
跟他一起做糖果和巧克力的品牌。
所以除非你去翻他代工厂的信息。
这种制造商的信息。
不然你看到的就只有卧极限。
像很多合码或者是敲腰。
我们看到他还会有商超加品牌。
放在同一个位置
同样大小
这渠道没有那么强势。
对
但是卧极限是没有的。
卧极限是看不到
任何一个品牌的字样的。
这其实就是沃尔玛。
改造这些门店的思路。
改造门店的原则
就是让这个门店更紧凑。
所以大概一万左右的 SKU。
基本上就是尽量以卧极限。
这么一个大的品牌形象出现。
我对比下来呢？
卧极限可能
最大的优势除了
我刚说他的选择
丰富到你无法想象以外。
他真的价格会相对合码和删目。
都还要再低一点
低可能在10%-15%左右。
不仔细对比
感觉不出来
因为我当时是一边手机上看。
合码和删目同类的定价。
就同包装的定价
一边看卧极限
他还是会比如说
合码是12块9
他这里是10块9。
大概这样的一个差异。
那他肯定是经过了。
精确的计算
能够一方面
从代工厂那里获得。
尽量多的利润空间。
同时他要和这些
已经成型的这种
自由品牌的渠道
去拉开距离
品质上的区别
可能没有那么直接的。
在购买那一瞬间
体会到最直接的就是价格。
然后还有一点就是。
他确实兼顾了删目和合码。
两个超市的容量包装。
既有小包装
也有超级大包装
比如说删目
它不是一个大的包装。
里有很多小包装吗？
我看到沃尔玛
甚至会把这小的
拆开卖
比如他有几十克的糖果。
但同时也有一大包。
里面有好几个
几十克的糖果
这一点我觉得
还挺聪明的
就是你即可一个人。
在卧机先买到
你一人时的小分量的东西。
如果你是家庭
你想更实惠
你也有大包装可选择。
但是他也没有开配送。
他可能是都想要
但实际的情况
会不会两边不靠呢？
我不太确定
他没有开配送
这个事情是
我觉得因为他们
确实没有配送机
没有电商机
所以可能是
这个改造才刚刚开始。
我看了一下
新闻稿
最近沃尔玛是宣布说。
在北京会接手
原来两家
华联旗下的超市
就是BHG的
原来的超市
将会由沃尔玛接手。
但在这之前
沃尔玛在北京
也只有五家门店了。
像你说的
在上海有三家门店。
他今年
计划要在全国范围内。
改造一百家门店
他门店数量
已经非常的少了
所以他能够改造的店。
也没有那么多
所以他能够辐射的。
半径
可能也没有那么的大。
一切都跟20年前不一样了。
沃尔玛他的
改造整个都在进行中。
不管是他门店
还是他卧极鲜的
PB的产品
还是他的小程序
这一切都还没有
达到一个
完全太的新的沃尔玛。
所以我们现在看到的。
就是觉得
他配缩范围比较小。
他的门店的装修
也没有升级
他的动线
或者他的审美
设计好像
也还没有跟得上
这个时代
是因为我们看到的。
都不是进化好的
比如说
到明年这个时候
我们再聊一期沃尔玛。
我们会发现
我们身边已经有了。
那种全新状态的沃尔玛。
以我在工作中
接触到沃尔玛的经验。
他们在选品的
严格程度上
甚至他们的工作人员。
在勤奋的程度上
在对产品质量的
严格要求上
确实是能看到
这种大企业身上的。
好的传统
但也有非常多
像这种传统超商
训练出来的人
流去了这种
所谓的新领寿
最近几年
我们不太提新领寿。
这个词了
其实是两种的大融合。
你想合码的基因杀。
里吗？
所以他一定会再配送。
在电商
在APP
这些事情上
做得更好一点
那沃尔玛的基因
是大卖厂
是在选品
在超市改造
甚至是在
这种会员体系里
做得更好一点
你猜一下
2008年的时候。
沃尔玛在中国
有多少家门店
2008年吗？
对
20年前吗？
100家
多一点
有120家
其实沃尔玛在中国。
区内巅峰时期
是有412家门店。
最近的5年
或者10年间
它有逐渐缩减
不到300家门店。
那现在又回到了一个。
重新去增加
更多门店的
这么一个状态
它在山谱
不是一个完全
此消彼长的状态
对
它在收缩的过程当中。
还是有其他的
像河马
西纤
线上的区道
丁东
小巷
去
缠实了它的份额
去了沃尔玛
实体店贯玩
觉得有点失望
回头再冷静想下来。
我还挺期待的
因为我就觉得
这么大的品牌
经过了
穿越了一个周期的。
这样的企业
我不认为它
会在这个时代里落后。
而且我们已经看到。
它正在变了
只是我们看到的是。
它正在变的过程
你还记得我们
当时最开始
河马还比较新潮的时候。
和区房还有这个概念。
你住在了
河马配送范围内
这个还是一个
有一点提升
生活质量的这么一个标签。
但你说的这点很重要。
握极先的它的定价。
会比山姆
会比河马
平均都要低那么一两块钱。
在我们当下的
经济形势
或者说消费
习惯
转变的这么一个过程当中。
如果每一个评类
都低了一两块钱的话。
可能是一个相对来说。
比较新一人的点了。
我们可能也没有在乎说。
这个牛奶
它是90%的好喝。
还是85%的好喝。
我确实被握极先的牛奶。
征服了
它的价格是9块9。
它的蛋白质含量是4。
它的好喝程度是100分。
握极先这个品牌
拿出的最好的一个打卷。
它确实有好几款产品。
做到了百分百好喝。
价格更低
营养啊？
健康都给到了一个。
接近满分90分的一个打卷。
但这就跟很多餐厅。
新餐厅
它刚开业的时候
会在大众点评上
上一个9块有的饮流款。
是一样的
那你把顾客
从广貿的人海当中。
靠饮流款吸引来了。
之后你怎么样平衡。
让顾客持续的复购。
复购更多的东西
以及平衡自己的利润。
门店 配送这些
这些都是20年前的沃尔玛。
没有面临过的竞争。
它现在有更多的
不同的角度的老师。
竞争对手
当然它也有可能
更多的空间
它面对的消费者
也完全不是同一代人。
也有不同的消费能力。
当时那个失望的感觉。
是来自于说
沃尔玛你还没有完全改造好。
但是我从社交媒体。
和文章的报道里
所得知的你
好像是已经改造好的。
这中间有一个落差感。
我在小红书上看到的是。
已经很新很新的沃尔玛了。
这就是怎么说
期待越大
失望越大
对 它通过宣传
通过设媒
打造出了一个
非常非常好的形象。
如果说
它是一个电商基因的公司。
那你打造出这个
很好的形象
我只需要在网络上。
享受你的服务
够买一就行了
偏偏你又是一个
大卖厂的公司
我得去献一下
那就会形成这个落差感。
中国市场和全球的这个公司。
一向都是需要去
面临一个去跟总部。
争取坏权
争取更多灵活性
这不是沃尔玛一家公司的问题。
很多大的公司
科技企业也好
零售企业也好
外企到了中国来
它中规都是有这么一个。
争取的过程
我们看到很多公司。
就是因为中国的这个分部。
跟总部之间
没有获得足够的灵活性。
导致他在中国市场。
水土不服
那这些年
重新要去站起来的。
这个沃尔玛的中国区。
他可能也面临
同样的问题
那我是不是要去总部。
呈现我已经有
一定的reputation。
那你可不可以给我。
更多的灵活程度
让我能够在这个
特别的市场
跟这些
可能美国总部
根本没有见过的这种。
竞争对手打的时候。
更自由
起码我不要说
我做一个代工厂的审核。
我要去跟总部来来来。
会会拉扯很多遍
是吧？
我如果拉扯三个月。
那竞争对手那个迟到。
已经把那个代工厂挖走了。
就把这个价格
又压避了20%
我再去重新battle。
我花菜都凉了呀？
对的
我听到他们说
中国市场的时候
听到两个特别
一个就是说中国市场特别大。
还有一个就是特别快。
如果你服务北上广深行。
和你往山东济南
你往陕西西安去服务。
是我完全不同的市场。
完全不同的消费习惯。
特别快是指
有一些东西
你以为在一线城
是发展得很快很好。
但是当你真的
再到那个更大的市场。
你去的时候
你发现他们当地早就有。
自己不同模式
就当地自己
生长出来的新的超市。
新的卖场
对
它不是一个
这种流动的状态
不是说
我从北上广深行
发展好了
我在流动到县城
可能很多东西
是从234县城
是流行起来
生活在北上广深行的。
人反而是有点成八老的感觉。
中国的各个地方
都会生长出自己
不同的商业模式
我记得前几年
社区团购的时候
那个东西是从长沙长起来的。
那就不是一个
由北京上海去影响长沙。
而是由长沙影响全国。
包括现在我们看到。
生鲜类的超市
其实是在很多山东。
河南的城市里有
你看看胖东来
胖东来从去年开始。
去调改像
污美这样的
北京的本土超市
其实也是很大的新闻。
甚至在北京的
本土居民
在那里也是一个很大的事情。
大家也都很期待
因为从各种的
新闻的营销号里边。
都能看到
说胖东来是一个
挺厉害 挺了不起的超市。
大家都很想去看
但不是人人都能去许唱吗？
胖东来一来改
污美
那老头老太太
连夜排队
去看那些
改造过的熟食柜台。
熟食种类
当然大家也有
各自的吐槽
但是在一个市场里面。
就是在零售新的东西。
它终归是能引起话题的。
不管是新的供应商。
新的产品
新的发售方式
说起来
你去过麦德龙吗？
20年前我们家
附近不远
就有一家麦德龙
那个时候麦德龙很神秘。
需要办会员卡才能进。
也得办会员卡
才能结账
大家传说这里面
卖的东西可好了
可便宜了
又可划算了
就有一点
我们现在
看Costco那种感觉。
麦德龙其实是
能个人办卡的
接近20年前
就大学毕业实习的时候。
实习的单位
以单位的名义
办了卡
一张卡就流传在
所有的人
需要采购的人
身上去用
有的时候
我们是得跟着
领导一起去采购
一路上
就是有三四个
从未进去过的
像我这样的实习生。
然后有一两个
去过的
跟我们介绍里面的。
像导游一样
进去之后发现
其实那些东西
我们也都见过
它没有卖
我们没有见过的东西。
包装价格
或者是售卖方式
规格不一样
对规格不一样
结账的时候
确实就会
出现很多的黄牛
在那里说
你要不要用我的卡。
麦德龙在长沙
最早他甚至
私企都不能办
你得是一个大的单位。
才能去向他那
申请办那样卡
我到现在都不知道。
麦德龙有没有个人会员。
他好像一直都是
只有企业会员
是
我们家在麦德龙旁边。
住了20年
一直到
可能2020年
我搜外卖的时候
突然发现
可以点到麦德龙的外卖。
我才第一次
消费了麦德龙
我在那旁边
就距离不到2公里。
住了20年
从来没有进去过
就是因为这种
神秘的都市传说
他现在可能开放
但是他最早
至少有10年内
他都是只有那种
大的企业
才可以拥有麦东的卡。
而且那张卡
通常会掌握在行政。
或者是人力
或者采购的手上
员工肯定是没有的。
这种神秘感
一直延续到了
我们对山姆的体验。
问了一下
住在北京大兴
和通州的朋友
他们说
其实山姆在北京
已经有10年了
就第一家山姆店
他开在顺义那边
那个时候是
有一些顺义
住在郊区的人
会开车去山姆
进货采购
但是顺义当地人
比如那些
还是习惯去买
新鲜食材的人
是看不上这种购物方式。
就是觉得去山姆
买的都动肉
顺义当时不是有很多的。
国际学校
也有很多的全职太太。
是他们最早
成为了山姆的客群。
我第一次办山姆的卡。
现在是2021年。
而且我办那张卡
是很特殊的
我都不知道这张卡。
现在还存不存在
叫京东山姆联名卡。
是因为我是京东会员。
然后有一天
我打开京东买东西的时候。
他就给我推送说
你现在加一个
多少多少钱
就可以在京东上
购买山姆的东西
对
那个时候是京东
和沃尔玛交叉持股。
各自有一些
非常深度的合作带来的。
对
我不知道山姆是有。
自己的独立APP的。
我以为他是类似
在京东开了个自营店。
我就顺着那个
一步步点下去
花了两百多
办了一张京东山姆联名卡。
我买了一些
他当时教授排行榜。
上最高的那些饼干。
是山姆到现在为止。
都是销量最高的那些。
虾片啊几样东西
就尝一尝吧？
那张卡我就只消费了一次。
我就忘记了
他会默默的就存在。
于你的京东账户里。
那张卡其实也是
可以去山姆线下
也可以去山姆
独立APP购物的。
虽然他是一个
被归在新灵兽里面。
被我们知道的东西。
但是因为他
重点还是线下嘛？
所以他跟距离
还是有非常明确的关系。
我们是因为天津的家。
住的离山姆很近
才跟山姆发生了
更多的关系
才发生就我们上期。
聊过的
比如说周末去山姆。
逛一逛啊？
杀一杀实在
让小孩玩一玩啊什么的。
一张会员卡
他不是说他可以给你。
抵用购物金还是怎么样。
他只是一个
你准入的资格
做一个商超
你如何让会员觉得。
你这个会员费
是能够物有所值的。
其实还是有门槛的事情。
对吧去年
非常大的风波是大家。
突然发现山姆有
非常多的品
换了供一商
或者说曾经
我们以为
只会出现在弯码
而不会出现在山姆。
这样的超水的东西。
进去了
我花了会员费
但是我进去买一些。
在外面都能买到的东西。
那我是不愿意的
那引起了非常多的。
消费者的反弹
也引起了从去年
到今年一系列的
山姆的高层的变动。
郭一军到底都是因为。
你200多这么一个。
主卡或者说100多的副卡。
你怎么能够把它
完全的直回来
这个是非常微妙的体验。
也一点一点的会影响到。
这么一个人们
对于这么一个
商超的接受程度
格马他的那个会员费。
其实也改来改去
改了很多
我第一次去山姆的时候。
其实也是被一个
类似非常喜欢山姆的朋友。
当导游一样带过去。
他详细的给我介绍。
他日常会在山姆
有哪些东西是必买的。
就像我之前说的
一个一个的去试吃跪台。
因为我们是一个
工作日去的
所以人其实不是很多。
体验就会比较好
山姆带回去的东西。
就比如说一盒蛋糕。
12个
那可能吃最快乐的就是。
第一个和第三个
到后面就变成
摊牌任务
你把它吃完
如果你觉得
像瑞士卷
或者面包
或者烤鸡翅
这些东西是量太大了的话。
你可以想想
每一年618双11。
你要吞的那些东西。
洗脸巾
失册纸
厨房用纸这些东西。
山姆都可以做到
在品质更高的情况下。
价格与大品牌
在双11的促销价一致。
这就是深刻研究过山姆的。
得出结论
我信任了
而且确实我对比下来也是。
山姆确实做到了
因为我们买失测值一买。
也是会买一箱
没有人只会买两包。
对吧？
我们住在北上广深行。
这个储存空间也很贵。
我们在计算
一个东西的价值的时候。
可能不一定光看它的价格。
也要看
它放在家里面
消耗的足经或者房价。
山姆的收纳赛道
可能就是这么活起来的。
我很爱看
我自己现在已经不买。
这种大包装的蛋糕。
布丁这种
但我很喜欢看
陈敬世修那山姆占力品。
分装
对对对
看它一点点分装
然后包起来冻起来。
但我们也知道
你冻过以后再拿出来吃。
理论上来说
营养没有什么流失。
食物不会变质
但就没有那么好吃。
我还是愿意
像在河马一样点餡吃。
或者说
很多时候我愿意在小巷。
跟丁东买小包装
小份量的
250克
一顿饭就吃完了
说实话
就是疫情那几年
造成了囤货的PTSD。
这个事情
我现在已经治疗好了。
北京和上海是非常严重的。
就是在那几年
形成了囤货的需求。
我从沃尔玛的朋友了解到。
山姆除了在北京上海以外。
销量第一的城市是沈阳。
东北他们好像天然。
就有这种囤货的习惯。
而且他们对于冷冻的。
不管是大白菜
东楚大白菜土豆
还是说冷冻的鲜肉。
他们是有生活习惯是这样的。
像欧美的那种电视剧里一样。
从冰箱拿出很多东西。
然后解冻
然后吃掉
反正我现在还没有这样的习惯。
这一点其实也会让很多的。
像您一样注重这种。
新鲜程度的人会有顾虑。
或许也是沃尔玛要。
再去从沃吉先这个角度。
考虑到不同的商品规格。
不同的接受人群
要去做这么一个改动的空间。
所在
我们囤的这些货到底是真的便宜了。
还是一种便宜的假象呢？
假设我现在从紫金。
到所有的消耗品开始。
我都不囤
我可能一年也多花不了多少钱。
省业省不了多少
它其实是从心理上。
给我造成了一种我占到了便宜。
你说中了一个很重要的点。
很多时候商超零售。
它就是在跟消费者心理在做博弈。
你还记得我们小的时候。
经常看到一个鸡汤。
比如说69.99。
或者6.9 6.8。
这样的定价它是有道理的。
它让你觉得它没有那么多。
但实际上它的这个定价。
是比你心理以为的定价要高的。
这都是消费者心理嘛？
迟到的不同
更加的细分
大家博弈的部分就更多了。
包括说沃尔玛去跟供应商。
去跟生产商这种代工品牌。
直接他们的博弈
他们的合作周期通常并没有太久。
合作条款通常都非常的严格。
在卧极先你根本看不到。
这些代工厂的品牌的任何痕迹。
他们统一都是让消费者感到。
这是卧极先
而不是来自莫小仙。
来自金麦朗
来自金地啊这样的具体的品牌。
因为它的整个品牌形象的建构。
就来自于沃尔玛
所有的利器都用在了这里。
而不是说我要借这种品牌的利。
说我这是谁是谁的。
你购不上的一些日常的品牌。
来到了我这里用一个比较低的价格。
它好像是两套不同的逻辑。
山姆上了好例有
溜溜梅惹怒了山姆的会员嘛？
我只想到了小的时候。
不管是看书买专辑。
买衣服买彩妆都非常信任。
当时能买到的时尚杂志上的编辑推荐。
山姆就是这个时代的一种编辑推荐。
别人帮我选好了
我不需要再去茫茫的商品海洋里。
再去选择的感觉
对你看山姆自由品海的名字。
叫member smock。
假设服装行业或者泳衣行业。
有一个这样的山姆。
那我是不是就可以省去。
我这些买 选 适 退的流程。
那不是优衣库跟穆基吗？
对啊？
一家也是呀？
山姆和马出现以前。
优衣库 穆基
一家就已经实现了品牌。
他们都不需要自由品牌。
他们本身就是
家具或者这件衣服。
这个零食它就是
我这个店的品牌的。
优衣库现在也卖花。
一家也有它的各种。
他们的品类都越来越广。
尤其是穆基啊？
现在什么彩妆 零食。
变成了百货商场
他们开始逐渐从他们的日杂服装。
开始扩充品类了
每一个货源制店商也好。
像这样的 穆基这样的品牌也好。
都想要做到的事情。
就是我通过这个品牌。
跟消费者建立了连接。
在消费者生活的所有的地方。
你就可以直接的完全的信任我。
但是问题是
我们作为消费者来说。
在当下这个物质
极大丰富的今天
我们确实是拥有无数的选择。
每一个这种百货公司。
都想抓住它的消费者。
但其实消费者
是在不断的变化的。
人就是喜心厌旧的呀？
你说一家优衣库
无印良品
他们是一种原生的自由品牌。
而不是像河马 山姆 沃尔玛 永辉这样。
重新长出来的
最早最早的时候
河马也好 山姆也好。
他们应该
很多的东西都是从品牌进的货。
选的品马
逐渐逐渐长出来自己的品。
打上自己的logo。
或者像我这些那样。
去品牌的话
全部变成自己的logo。
而一家从第一天开始。
就是一家
无印良品
从第一天开始就是无印良品。
就在扩品类
一家你看他的新的东西。
他可能是买设计
或者我们这些年看到的是跟设计师。
包括跟Hey这样的品牌。
去联名 去做设计。
但是他的对于生产。
销售的整个全流程。
是把控更强的
而商超调取调
把控没有那么强
而是靠跟贡运商的。
这种合作的连接去控制。
消费者其实不管这些的。
消费者当然有
会想说我想要很多。
有一段时间
我可能想无脑的去买。
比如说像册子
写脸巾这样的东西。
我可能想无脑的去买。
那像服装
或者说新的零食
这些新的刺激
那我可能就会
你这段时间
这一家没有
给到足够的新东西。
那我可能就看另一家了。
原生的这种渠道品牌。
或者是原生的百货公司。
你会看到一个人
你会觉得这个人
他是一个优异库人。
因为他穿的就是
哪怕他其实不是优异库。
但那个风格是优异库。
或者你看到一个家的装修。
这个家是完全的一家。
对吧？
但是河马和山姆
他们是目前还没有形成一种。
比如打开一个冰箱。
是完全的河马山姆。
这种制霸地位
感觉山姆在有一段时间里面。
可能做到了
或者说他想要呈现的是。
一个中产阶级的家庭。
大家的消费基本上。
都是在山姆
但是中产这个概念。
或者说中产的财富等级也好。
或者消费能力也好。
在这几年也发生了很大的变化。
被虚构写作的题都是。
中产被困在叉叉里。
是吧？
有的说感觉中产就是骂人的话。
实际上是被塞进了。
一个一个标签里面。
但消费者
作为一个具体的消费者。
可能并不愿意被打上标签。
作为商超渠道也好。
作为品牌也好
就是要不断的面对。
消费者
这种喜心厌旧的这个消费现实。
以及他们的消费能力。
如何在喜心厌旧的人性。
和消费能力的变迁。
和这种不同的
触达渠道里面
抓住消费者的那一个购买的行为。
真的是一个很复杂的生意。
对他们面临的不只是消费者的变化。
或者消费能力
经济环境的变化
还有非常复杂
非常卷的他人对手。
因为这个赛道里在不断的。
涌现出新的模式
新的品牌
新的产品在吸引走他们的消费者。
因为大家忍就这些人。
能力也就这些能力。
但是五花八门的
整个的消费市场在吸引着大家。
你看到这一波这种自由品牌热。
因为上海非常夸张。
上海甚至有了一个叫自由品牌协会。
他们甚至办了线下的大的展会。
展会里展的都是各个商超的自由品牌。
或者是由那些愿意为商超。
做自由品牌的厂家。
来展示自己的能力的这样一个展会。
由论坛
上海真的是走在非常前列。
想到了王一言选
还有包括以前什么必要商城。
京东京造这一系列。
线上的自由品牌商城。
出来的时候
大家的这种关于品牌和代工厂的。
野心野望
对吧？
大家都想要靠一个大的品牌。
去抓住消费者
但是在小的一个工厂也好。
在小的一个实体也好。
它可能都有一个
想要做品牌的野心。
哪怕是我们个人
我们也希望有一个自己的名字。
被别人所知道
在你没有大足够强的时候。
你需要去依赖这些迟到。
包括你做一个博主。
可能这个IP
也要依赖一个平台的渠道。
在你长大的过程当中。
你会发现你原先想要仗度的利益。
并没有那么心甘情愿的送出去。
那平台在你长大的过程当中。
也会对你有所忌惮。
这一切都是商战
都是谋略
我其实有看到一个。
食品行业的比较严肃的媒体。
在批评这种
所谓的自由品牌
它写的一篇文章
它觉得这是一种过渡包装。
其实本质是代工加贴牌。
代工加贴牌这个模式。
在我们国家已经太熟悉了。
我们为无数的
全世界的产品代工加工。
很多很多年了
那你觉得这一波所谓的。
批避的热潮
它本质上是代工加贴牌吗？
还是它有什么变化呢？
它是未来吗？
它是一个持续滚动的。
现在我们国家可能从。
都不要说是最近几十年了。
上世纪二十三十年代。
在近代开始
像潮汕那边的抽纱。
都是出口的
这个全球流动
虽然说全球化有放缓。
有逆形
但是中国人的这个。
制造产业
确实还是非常的强大。
甚至可能说
我们的这个消费能力。
都没有接住这些
庞大的制造能力
所溢出的这种品牌业心。
对我们的制造能力。
就是溢出到全世界了。
我以前跟好多人都推荐过。
一开始是因为我老公。
买了一个代工厂的股票。
那个代工厂上市
他就不满足
一直是代工厂
他就做自己的店商。
也有自己的品牌
他是一个
专门做锅的品牌
叫卡罗特
他的商品便宜到
至少在当时我
第一次逛他的淘宝店的时候。
令人发指
在我们被国内的大品牌。
还有国外的大品牌的锅具。
所洗脑的时候
我们认为一个好的锅。
它至少得是几百块。
甚至更好的是一千块。
两千块三千块的锅。
但在那个店里
它最贵的锅
就是一百块
如果你算上淘宝的。
各种优惠大折
用了这么多年下来。
我也没有用出来
他和我过去
购买过的
三百五百一千的锅的差距。
更可怕的是
他应该是为了要
更好的服务消费者。
他的策略是
一年免费换新无理由。
所以相当于
你一百块买一个锅。
因为我们知道很多的。
尤其是有图层的锅。
它是一个消耗品
就一百块买一个
30厘米的锅
一年内还可以再换一个。
你的使用成本只有50块。
这也太拼了
这个卷的程度
但是因为这个电酸。
它可能作为淘宝店。
已经很大
它依然不是一个
被很多人知道的品牌。
它依然没有成为
类似像什么双利人。
或者是我们知道的特服。
这种全世界知名的品牌。
它的销量依然还是不如他们的。
只是作为一个消费者。
我说原来其实锅的成本。
因为它50块卖给我。
它还是赚钱的呀？
那么我那些
500块买的平底锅。
算什么呢？
这些超市去做自由品牌。
其实就是想要把这些品牌。
这些原来做500块的。
涂层锅的这些品牌的。
这种利润空间
给它打掉
用来换取
这些商超品牌
对于消费者的信任。
卡罗特可能是我
第一个接触信任
并且长期使用的
由代工厂做起来的品牌。
我才开始知道
原来制造业和
最终到零售端
中间的链条和利润。
居然是这么大的
我们在商超里面
看到的那些
常规的一些零食
它的毛利率
至少要是在40%。
50%
像服装它的毛利率。
可能是80%
不然它可能赚不到钱。
对
所以接下去
就下一期播客
我们就要聊一下义务。
我下一次要去的线下。
逛街
就是准备出发去义务。
商超品牌
或者自由品牌的建立。
是在打掉
很多的所谓国际大牌。
或者国内大牌的品牌溢价。
让购物的链条变得更短。
工厂离消费者之间的。
那个更近一点
这不是跟淘宝天猫。
京东这些
或者拼多多这些
想说的一样吗？
没有中间商传差价。
但我们知道
只是中间商换了形式。
换了名字
换了样子
但是如果说
它的价格是低的
品质是高的
我觉得中间商是谁都行。
对中间商他要干的。
当然还有包括把控品质。
把控这个标准
设计合适的包装
我们现在是一个
现代社会
我们没有能力去面对。
非常原始的这些素材。
对 所以就是
我刚刚说的那个
媒体上的一篇负面文章。
就是说
其实我们认为
商超自由品牌
在追求极致的品质和性价比。
它的观点是
这些大的商超渠道。
一定只在追求极致的利润。
但这中间我觉得是有平衡的。
因为它要向消费者展示。
展示它的能力
然后营取消费者信任。
那它就需要通过
极致的品质和极致的性价比。
但是与此同时
它作为一个企业要发展。
它确实要追求极致的利润。
这两者之间
肯定也是一种
它内部的博弈
开始我们考虑
这中间在网易言选账的品牌的时候。
我们考虑的是
这中间没有什么知识产权的问题吗？
但是现在我们可能。
不讨论在卧级先这样的。
在山姆河马这样的渠道里面。
我们不用去讨论知识产权。
他们自己解决了这些问题。
傅迪是不是典型的。
水土不服的超市
傅迪
我们从消费者的体验来看。
我不管它是不是水土不服。
它给我带来了新鲜的体验。
对
很漂亮
它的设计很好看
水土不服的典型案例就是开市客。
是我一个上海的朋友。
他非常热情的送了我一张年卡。
让我开卡使用
我就用Cosco的那个小程序。
去想试着购物
当然他也有很高的配送门槛。
我想让那人家卡都送我了。
无论如何
我得消费一单
但是这件事情的结果就是。
整整一年时间
我尝试了四五次
我都没有买成功
我绑定了卡
注册了会员
然后我就开始选品。
然后发现
它的品的展示的信息非常的少。
它不像山姆那样
有一个非常完善的品牌页面。
然后我就去问我这个朋友。
他就说
你买就好了
因为他们家都是在那买。
他说这个苏打水
我都非常好喝的
我就按照他的指定。
我差不多在购物车。
加400块的东西。
我在支付环节
就反复的被卡出去。
页面就崩掉了
然后这是头几次
后面我终于
还是用到了一张Visa的信用卡。
绑定好了它的校程序去买。
但是没有支付成功。
显示我就是一直支付失败。
当时又一直弹出
说我们家的配送范围。
还是怎么样
我做了多次尝试之后。
最后终于放弃了会员卡。
好像那些东西
我也没有非要去买的。
他没有信到我
我们顺便的选择有足够多。
它的小程序的使用体验。
实在是太差了
已经耗尽了
我作为一个
就是观察型消费者的。
所有的耐性
我觉得这就是典型的。
水土不复
因为他们没有想过。
可能在中国逛超市的人。
还是少的
一开始我们一定得要通过。
一个便捷的方式
去触达到
能够网购到
如果我真的买到
到家里觉得真的不错。
那我下一次
就会开车去逛他
山姆这一点
就做得比他好很多。
山姆确实他的APP。
包括他的急速达的配送。
真的是很符合
我们的消费习惯的。
这确实是一个
非常不一样的市场。
已经被外卖
被廉价的这种劳动力。
所塑造的一个
关于线上和线下
精致完全不同
与其他市场的市场。
对 而且因为
你想美国加拿大那种地方。
家家都弄一个大皮卡。
一个房子和一个房子之间。
那么老远
他们一周去采购一次。
家庭生活物质资
这是他们的生活习惯。
但对我们来说
就是每天我下楼
走到711
就能把我要喝的饮料买到。
所以我们才说山姆。
是我们被当成
旅游景点
和六娃的地方的选择。
我们可以逛的
周边的超市
太密集 太多选择。
问题还是在于
我们可以逛的这些。
实在是太多了
我的客户
他最近在美国
我经常看他发回来的一些。
他拿Pokey的拍的。
美国的超市的视频。
我发现还是有很多。
这不一样的
比如说那些动线设计。
那些烘焙区的设计。
或者是那些深仙区的设计。
还是跟我们国内
超市不一样
客户也说
要学一些
更先进的超市的理念。
回来应用到我们现在的。
就是产品上
或者是超市的供给上。
他有非常多的学问。
对 他有太多的学问。
而且他还是那么大。
那么丰富
同时跟我们的生活息息相关。
没有那么冷冰冰的。
所以希望大家
多多关注我们的逛街专家。
我们会和大家一起。
再逛更多的街
不管你是去Ui库。
去奥勒奇
还是去附地
任何一个在你的城市。
如果你在的城市有一些。
我们没听过的超市景台。
我们可以肉身去逛一下。
对 欢迎跟我们分享。
好的
那今天就聊到这里。
拜拜